Oh
[Music]
all right so the idea is to believe in a
more brilliant of course this requires a
childlike state of oneness Alan
Harrington wrote an immortal Asst we
must all remain uncompromising child
voyagers retain a child's eye view of
what might be what happens with adults
is that we become jaded you know the bin
there's have done that to the adult mind
it's a form of laziness it's a form of
dispensing with the here and now and
jumping to the conclusions it's the sort
of impatience with lived life that we
need to transcend we need to re-engage
with the senses we need to awaken the
minds attention from the lethargy of
custom and the film of familiarity and
redirecting it instead to the wonders of
existence
you know absolute unmixed attention is a
form of Prayer
looking begins with love love begins
with looking this is the eye of the
child this is the mind of the child
we're all born artists we're all born
ecstasy seekers and then it just kind of
gets like pummeled out of us it gets
like stripped away by banality
what is banality and boredom if not
defenses the educated mind employs
against experience so that it's not
continually exhaustingly astonished as
Michael Pollan wrote in the botany of
desire and it's true it would be
astonishing to be open to it all at any
given time just read James Joyce but we
must nonetheless strive to reenter these
spaces because these are the only spaces
that have ever led to visions that have
transformed the world that my friends is
that
you